هذا الفيديو الذي نتابعه الان بثيتوا قوات
فاجنر لما تقول انه انتشار للقوات في وسط
باخموت اذا هذه صور نشرتها مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه
لقواتها وتقول انها دخلت الى باقمت كنا قد
تابعنا واياكم على مدار الاشهر الماضيه
هذه المعارك التي كانت تطوق
مدينه مدينه باقمت في اقليم هذه صور معارك
ضاريه كانت طبعا بالقرب من هذه المدينه
ومحاوله السيطره على هذه المدينه من قبل
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه القوات الاوكرانيه
كانت تقاوم خلال الاشهر الماضيه وكانت
المعارك مستعره في هذه المنطقه بالامس كنا
قد تابعنا مع مراسل العربيه في هذه
المنطقه التطورات جديده وذكر بان مجموعه
قريبه من مركز المدينه لم يتبقى لها لها
سوى اقل من اثنين كيلو متر حتى الوصول الى
داخل هذه المدينه والى مركز هذه المدينه
الان مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه تنشر صور
لقواتها وتقول انها داخل باخ موت ونتابع
هذه الصور اثار الدمار في كل مكان ربما
بعد هذه المعارك الضاريه والشد
والجذب العسكري في هذه المنطقه
وهذه المدينه مدينه باخموت وهي طبعا تعتبر
مدينه من المدن الاستراتيجيه في الشرق
الاوكراني من المدن التي دارت ريحه
المعارك فيها خلال طبعا الاسابيع والاشهر
الماضيه كانت طبعا قد تحدثت القوات او
الجيش الاوكراني كذلك ايضا خلال الساعات
الماضيه عن امكانيه الانسحاب من هذه
المنطقه
نائب اوكراني ايضا تحدث عن الانسحاب عن من
هذه المنطقه عاجلا ام اجلا القوات الروسيه
كنا قد تبعناها خلال الساعات القريبه
الماضيه
وكان تواصل اكمال الطوق حول اباخ مدمن
الناحيه الغربيه الدفاع الاوكرانيه ايضا
قبل ذلك صرحت بان روسيا تواصل التقدم في
محور باخموت وبعد ذلك اعلنت نقل قوات
اضافيه الى داخل
على حده المعارك في باخمه وقال بانها
تتزايد ايضا كذلك الان في هذه الصور التي
نتابعها واياكم على شاشه العربيه هي الصور
او فيديو طبعا مجموعه باجنر الروسيه وهي
تدخل هذه المدينه مدينه
رئيس مجموعه باك ناري يقول بان رجالي
اصبحوا وسط مدينه باخمت في